[Music]
a big step forward on the vaccine front
today the fda has cleared the way for
children as young as five to receive low
dose shots distribution could start as
early as next week but a lot of parents
still have questions sasha loftis
explains
david kohlmeyer's top priority is
keeping his kids healthy the bottom line
is you know you want to keep your
children safe he and his wife are
vaccinated against covid19 and do their
best to protect their family
which is why friday's authorization of
pfizer shot for young children sparked a
serious conversation i'm for the shot
but i'm also a little bit nervous the
fda has cleared kid-sized doses a third
of what adults get for anyone five to 11
years old
a few more hurdles remain but shots
could be in arms as early as next week
and dr christina madison calls this a
real step forward it's one more
milestone that we need in order to get
to a point where we can really
not just survive but thrive following
this pandemic she urges families to
explore options as soon as they can and
if you're hesitant she says don't be
afraid to ask your doctor please make
sure that you're getting your questions
answered and go to someone who you like
know and trust kohlmeyer is leaning
towards immunization but no matter what
he's just happy to have a choice it's
always better to have the option than
not having the option and he hopes other
parents move forward with what's best
for them every family has to make their
own decision sasha loftis live local now